Oooh! Now you found it!
No way!
What's up guys!
We are Pongfinity
It's time for another episode of Challenge Pongfinity
Okay, a 360 between every shot
I got no idea...
I think I changed direction in between the rally
Yeah, you did.
I forgot to turn around...
Wow
Just couldn't see it anymore
Okay one more
This is the worst challenge ever
Is that good?
This is definitely not fun
I think we are going to have to finish this challenge here
Okay so this is a challenge for you guys
Can we reach 100k likes on this video?
Let's see
Remember to like!
Many of you have wanted me to play with my beard
It's time to try it out
I'll try to attach this racket to my beard
That's now in place
Does it stay?
Maybe it will stay for a while
Let's try it!
This is never going to work out...
Yeah, that's not going to work
No, it's not.
Lower
Yeah, maybe now
That was close
I'm impressed if you get one shot on the
table
100,000 likes for every shot that Otto gets on table
So zero
Yeah, exactly!
Wow! Now you found it!
No way!?
Was that around the net?
That was unbelievable!
Emil has no chance against me!
Apparently it works!
I got the feeling now
I think I look quite stupid right now
Yes, you definitely do!
This is good!
Nice!
Stabilize the racket
Time for my favorite shot
You know what it is
I think this might be too hard
Okay
Not this time
I still have the world record in the Pongfinity game
But can I play this game
while I'm playing table tennis?
Of course, I'll choose Emil
*The best character*
And by the way
You probably haven't seen this
But this is the...
Rooftop
This is the best map in the whole game
I don't think I have seen it
How does it look like?
Nice
This could be a challenge
Play while someone else is holding it in front of you
Okay, go
It's going well?
Well, 16.
And guys go beat my high
score!
I want to see someone beat my high score
Emil challenges you guys
Yeah, that's my challenge to you guys
Go beat my high score!
I think you guessed what we are going to do with this
Let's try it out
The golden button would be big for
anybody else
But for Otto it's okay size
It's a bit high
Otherwise it's okay
That's good!
Otto will play with the button
I'll play with the case
What a fake shot
Yeah, fake shot
I think I'll start keeping my
racket in here
It's a bit inconvenient
But...
I like it
That was close!
It's time for the golden around the net!
Touched?
Yes
Golden plate vs silver plate
I'll take the winning plate
I think this one's better
But this is the winner's choice
Bigger plate for a bigger man!
Exactly
Okay, 0-0
Can i serve?
Yes, you can
That was a bad start
No chance that I'm going to beat you!
I'll try this side
Nobody wants to miss
We will be here tomorrow
playing this one point
Maybe this is the new world's longest rally
Maybe the black side is better
I'll finish it with the black side
Maybe we don't need to show the whole match
We just show this one point
This is as long as a match
Every time you just give me an easy ball
and I think I can smash it
But no
That's my tactic
10-4
I'm coming back
Thanks!
Stupid!
Easy!
Damage control
It seems to have survived
Just a little fingerprints
Some ball marks
It's Pongfinity approved now
Don't forget to subscribe
And watch our previous videos there!
Until next time!